The latest projections by the UN suggest the world population...
...could grow to around 8.5 billion by the end of this decade,...
...9.7 billion by 2050 and expected to peak at around 10.4 billion...
...during the 2080s and remain at that level until 2100.
The report also points to half the projected increase in global population...
...rise up to 2050 coming from just eight countries,...
...five in Africa:...
...The Democratic Republic of Congo,...
...Egypt,...
...Ethiopia,...
...India,...
...Nigeria,...
...Pakistan,...
...The Philippines and Tanzania.
With warnings coming from the UN that with rapid population growth...
...comes greater difficulties in eradicating poverty and combating hunger...
...while the need to increase health care and education coverage becomes key.
And while India is expected to become...
...the most populous nation in the world later this year,...
...global population growth has slowed,...
...with global fertility expected to keep declining...
...from around five births per woman in the 1950s...
...to around 2.1 births per woman by 2050.
Global population will continue to grow and could reach 9.7 billion in 2050.
It is projected to reach a peak of around 10.4 billion people...
...during the 2080s and to remain at that level until 2100.
The projected global population of 10.4 billion at the end of the century...
...is more than a half a billion lower than what we projected three years ago.
The report also says that globally,...
...the world counts slightly more men than women in 2022,...
...at a ratio of 50.3% for men and 49.7% for women,...
...a ratio expected to be equal by 2050.
Sherwin Bryce-Pease, SABC News, New York.